did you ever take out an ATM statement
and just go over a month ago it's got
the best taco in a man City team oh hi
I'm Tom Ward and welcome to in my
personal space my guest today is used to
a bit of our G bar G in the box but how
will he cope nose to nose with me
introducing Kyle Walker car hello hi hi
do you feel comfortable right now no not
really I'm really hot I'm hot too oh
yeah okay but where are you looking at
me so I can't look at your eyes I'm now
it's too close yes I'm looking it like
your mouth either seen a blur okay Kyle
if I'm gonna be in your personal space
we should have some of these romantic
did you ever take out an ATM statement
and just go whoa
that's better than when I was 18 no do
you ever take out an ATM statement let's
leave it at the ATM and then just watch
the next person read it in your car and
then drive off No why not it'd be funny
wouldn't it that I don't think I get
that much of it was out of it you're too
nice mate that's your problem if you
want to go to the next level and go get
a bit nasty by leaving my bank statement
at the ATM yeah just stop meddling with
people a little bit show them who's
daddy when was the last time you were
this close to someone probably complain
actually got one missus oh yeah yeah
tell me about it now she's very
different ball is still tap each other
on the bump to offer encouragement yeah
oh yeah yeah who's got the tenderest bum
in the team not that I felt everyone's
born but for what I felt is probably
Sterling's oh yeah yeah quite capable
hmm I don't think it's Tupper Bop I
wouldn't say it's palpable no
I fed Johnstone's is to be multiple oh
yeah yeah
what's more terrible about it yeah it's
just nice firm all right give us a bit
more yeah little bit more slack in it
who's got the best tackle in a man City
team Vincent Kompany oh yeah yeah do you
pick up the coins again thrown at you
and put them a little jar for a rainy
day and now I probably give it to Chari
oh that's nice mmm you could you say the
right things Carl what's your favorite
song that your own fans sing to you sing
to me yeah I don't think I've got one in
the minute no no your own fans don't
sing your name mm-hmm no I don't think
they do right sure well that must hurt
no he's fine it's fine
you sure completely fine it's not a
one-man sports a team game are you sure
it's fine I'm 100 percent sure it's fine
I've got some suggestions go for it Kyle
Kyle Walker good and play since a half
couldn't no think you like meat the work
up there now you got a play on the right
hmm thank you everyone knows that
have you changed since you started being
an elite athlete you're at the top level
now top top top level
have you changed no I think I've stayed
the same well I still got the same set
of friends still feel that my feet
firmly on the ground
she must be normal I am normal how many
cars have you got what how many cars
have you got - how many cars have you
got - that mine my missus I won three
what does she drive a car good when was
the last time you cried the birth of my
youngest son who's your favorite child
no or feet a little more all the same
well done
in a single noise how would you describe
your style fashion style in a single
noise how would you describe your
playing style my hair style your hair
style oh it's hot
I don't know telling yourself off yeah I
don't know if it was a good tuck though
I know it can't really be a good took on
it
that seems generous Carl thanks for
letting me in your personal space thank
you for having me has it been very well
yeah yeah
would you like to tap my bum I'd like to
give you a great big hug okay yeah I'll
take that as a rejection and an embrace
at the same time lovely just so much
better now
yeah who's your favorite kid
[Laughter]
[Music]